world-renowned dancer misty copeland
pays homage to the black ballerinas who
pave the way for her to break barriers
she has written a new book that profiles
27 dancers to inspire the next
generation i'm thrilled to welcome misty
copeland to quick take to talk more
about her latest labor of love black
ballerina misty it's so good to speak
with you
congratulations on your new book this is
your seventh book to be published so far
and i don't know how you find the time
for it but i wonder how long you've been
thinking about planning and kind of
mentally writing this book
yeah this is this is i feel so proud of
this because i feel like it's my my
life's work i feel like my purpose
has been to go beyond the stage and use
my platform and my voice to really
uncover our history as black people in
ballet so this has really been
throughout my journey of of you know
being in ballet since the age of 13
being the only black woman often uh you
know growing up in in the settings of my
training in classical dance and then
joining american ballet theater and
being the only black woman in the
company for the first decade of my
career i feel like it's you know it's
something that i've needed to do to feel
like i belonged and to feel like i was
making the right choices and being a
part of this this art form but it's an
it's incredible to have found so much of
our history that hasn't been documented
as black
as black ballerinas throughout you know
the 400 years that bali has existed yeah
you're trying to connect yourself to
this lineage of black ballerinas and
it's obviously very personal for you you
profile 27 ballerinas is there any one
dancer that you connect with the most
that lingers with you that you think
about when you're dancing when you're
not dancing that you kind of keep coming
back to all the time
oh that's so hard you know 27 i i have
been such a an impact in my life but
they are far from the long lineage of
black dancers like this is not a
comprehensive list but if i had to
choose one you know raven wilkinson who
passed away a couple of years ago was
someone who came into my life a black
ballerina who danced in the 1950s with
the bally rooster onto clock de monte
carlo she was the first black ballerina
to dance in that company and dealt with
a lot of adversity and racism in the
south and the kkk and you know things
that i can't even imagine dealing with
but she came into my life and kind of
gave me a second win to believe that i
did belong on this journey as a
classical dancer and that there was a
much brighter future than i even
imagined but it was having knowing her
story knowing that i was a part of his
history bigger than myself um that gave
me the motivation to keep going that's
great and that's what you bring and give
to the next generation of dancers as
well you talked about how you were the
only black woman when you joined the
american ballet theater abt and for many
years the only black ballerina you were
however surrounded by a lot of male
dancers male black dancers and you saw
the way that they navigated the white
ballet world
why is there such an imbalance first of
all and what did you learn from these
male colleagues
yeah you know it's it's difficult to
find boys that want to participate in
dance um which is mind blowing to me
because it's it's an it's a sport it's
an athletic feat you know we're not
competing like sports but it's that
uh it takes that much uh physical
dedication and commitment and sacrifice
to be a part of but we're just
constantly lacking enough boys so uh the
ballet world has been open to taking
brown and black boys over black women
because we desperately need them um but
it's been
such a big part of my journey to be able
to step back and watch how others
navigate to learn how i want to proceed
i've never been someone that just kind
of like stepped up and and and kind of
spoke before i really understood what
you know the situation of things and
i've really just learned that way by
watching how other people operate and
learning you know it's like just
learning how humans connect and and
interact and that's been one of my
strengths in navigating this very white
world in this very white field
is learning how to communicate with
people in a way where it feels like it's
a it's a conversation and it's not kind
of one-sided or an attack yeah that's
definitely a skill set that you are
forced to develop and obviously you've
done it well
you may not realize this misty but
you're quoted a lot on twitter every few
hours someone quotes you on twitter and
there's a quote attributed to you i mean
i was looking through it and recently a
very popular one is the path to your
success is not as fixed and inflexible
as you think now i'm not sure when you
said this but i'm curious as to how it
applies now
has the pandemic changed your idea of
what success looks like
um yeah it absolutely i think has
changed so much for everyone in the
world uh for me uh it's it's opened up
the arts in a way that i never imagined
it would in my lifetime you know i've
been fighting for more diversity and for
having the conversations about racism in
ballet and including more people making
it more inclusive and within the
pandemic i feel like we grew you know in
leaps and bounds you know just within
the last year and a half by you know
witnessing
the murder of george floyd by having
this racial reckoning the ballet world
has really kind of stepped back and
looked at themselves and thought how can
we improve um and so i think it's
definitely changed how i see the future
of dance and how i see the contributions
of black and brown people within within
this field moving forward i'm so glad
you mentioned that because another quote
that came up a lot is one where you say
be strong
be fearless be beautiful and believe
that anything is possible when you have
the right people there to support you so
in the wake of george floyd and black
lives matter
what kinds of people or institutions or
organizations have stepped up to show
their support
um
you know it's
i what's been surprising for me is
um just people's people's understanding
and hearing things in a different way
uh by having this collective reckoning
so for me it's not so much one person or
institute institution but you know for
instance okay maybe it is an institution
american ballet theater the company i
dance for like i've been very impressed
with how they've stepped up internally
you know and it's not something that
often has been a show when you think
about diversity initiatives especially
in in fields where it's uh you know
majority white and not very diverse you
know it's not just about
putting me on the cover of a pamphlet
and saying okay we've checked our
diversity box but the but the work
that's being done behind the scenes
right now at american ballet theater i'm
so proud to be a part of this company um
the conversations the real conversations
we're having about you know the the the
microaggressions the the the vocabulary
that's being used uh you know ways of
really progressing forward and being
more inclusive um that to me is is the
brightest
thing i could see in terms of how we
move forward in this world and i hope
the burden is not on someone like you to
do the work and show everyone how to get
there as well i mean that's on everyone
to do that i wonder as well given the
pandemic that we're in still a lot of
people have experienced burnout have you
experienced burnout during the pandemic
this has been an interesting time for me
and i'm i'm definitely not you know
the typical person like i feel like i'm
in a very fortunate position for me this
has been a moment for me to step back
and really dive into things i
haven't had time to do
you know being in a classical being in
this field being in classical ballet you
know we have a short careers and there's
not often a lot of time to stop and
really think about
how what else i want to do outside of
performing on stage and so though i've
been fortunate to be able to write books
and
you know speaking engagements and things
like this this has been a moment for me
to really step back and reflect on how i
can uh bring the most value to you know
my reach and my platform um you know
without just being a symbol on the stage
and so this has been a very
um reflective time that i feel like i've
grown in so many ways
uh in seeing myself as a leader not just
on the stage but even more so behind the
scenes and inspiring and impacting
influencing the next generation to be
able to do the work that i'm doing and i
want to pick up on that idea because i
know you think a lot about empowering
the next generation black ballerinas is
a great example of that but the thing is
in professional ballet competition is
cutthroat i mean especially if you're an
underrepresented minority it's easy to
feel that there's only room for one
woman in
the c-suite or one black ballerina
soloist katie couric for instance talked
about how being generous and mentoring
young women younger women um can
sometimes feel like you're grooming your
successor
did you see any evidence of that in your
research for your book
um
i've always
i've always felt very comfortable in
this position so i don't feel like you
know writing this book is kind of the
first time i'm entering into this this
uh
position or feeling this responsibility
of like being a mentor but um i think
it's i think it's you know part of my
responsibility of being in this position
to
uh expose more dancers of color because
it's so it's so empowering when you know
there's more than just you out there
it's something that's maybe not in your
you know that's in your subconscious but
when you think you're the only one it's
even more cutthroat and you really do
believe that there's only one spot but
the more that we support one another
especially as females you know to have a
sisterhood and support one another um
there's just always a better outcome for
me it's been it's never been about how
there being one spot at abt i've done
everything in my power to bring
young brown and black girls up after me
whether it's reaching out and to the
school at american ballet theater trying
to get scholarships for these students
showing the staff that they are out
there and exist that's how we progress
misty fantastic to speak with you